Jeff Garlin comedian actor producer
director writer he is on the Goldbergs
that way airs Wednesdays at 8:00 on ABC
nine time Emmy nominee ladies and
gentlemen by the way that is a strange
credit a 19 Emmy nominee which means
nine time Emmy loser
would you rather win once like one for
one yeah or Oh for nine one rather win
once and never be nominated again 42
times or win once and then there's a
whole weird thing that happens on stage
and you didn't actually win I'd want
that too do you have a speech written no
I'm an improviser man I got nothing to
say until I say it okay so if I said and
the winner is Jeff Garlin all right hey
thank you hey this is cool see you later
okay okay thank you
yeah I said thank you yeah thank ya
that's all that's all got planned for
right now you didn't I don't know what
do you want to win for the Goldbergs or
curb I don't want to win for I don't
yeah that's weird too I don't want to
win for Jeff got an award for just being
me oh well then that's the award you're
the only one who can win if you're just
it's the Jeff Garlin or knowing damn
well the odds are in my favor all right
if I say what ordered you won your
comedian an actor producer director
writer or is it actor comedian comedian
comedian comedians comedian involves all
the other things
comedians everything okay yeah did you
start his stand-up yes I started when I
was 20 years old week after my 20th
birthday
I started stand-up 1984 do you remember
your first joke well yes I do my first I
remember my
it was doing an Adam West impression it
was doing a monologue from the movie
stripes and yeah Lee Harvey you were a
madman when you stole that cow and your
friend I did that whole monologue
I did an Adam West impression which I
still it appears to me Commissioner
Gordon I didn't ask you to play Batman
though did that no they did not
damn them you would have thought by the
way along the way that they would have
asked me to play Fred Flintstone I did
by the way here's a little bit of trivia
so John Goodman got it yeah John Goodman
and then that English dude who did
whatever but the the point be I actually
was asked to be a new animated Fred
Flintstone with the dude from Family Guy
what's a as named stuff yeah Seth
MacFarlane I'm always bad at MacFarlane
was gonna be Barney and I was gonna be
Fred Flintstone but it didn't happen
okay we might still how do you sound his
fred flintstone
[Laughter]
was the comedian coming up that you just
went Wow when you were younger when I
was younger who was the guy that blew my
mind well you know when I was younger
you know who I thought was amazing
was Bill bill were gone I'll tell you
about the Chicago Bears all you want
Bill Hicks bill hello yeah I thought was
like wow I actually saw him do a set in
Chicago where he was bombing harder from
the beginning and he dug himself out of
it to kill harder than anyone I've ever
seen
it was amazing he didn't purposely dig
the hole you know no he was just in a
hole
and he just kept going and he was
brilliant truly brilliant also Sam
Kinison I worked with Sam Kinison before
he became famous and I remember watching
him and I hung out with him we went out
every night no boy he offered me tons of
cocaine every night like he did tons of
cocaine I didn't do it I was 20 I was 20
years old but when I say was a free
cocaine he was doing it but he was the
most lovely man he was so supportive and
watching him on stage one of two things
happened it was either
he killed bigger than anyone I'd ever
seen ever or it was like someone pulled
a fire alarm that's how quickly it
wasn't even like that he bombed people
left that quickly they were offended
they were offended like literally the
roomful of 300 people would be like 80
people in a matter of 10 minutes yep but
did he want that
no he wanted all of us acceptance but
the great ones don't care like in other
words you do what you do and either
people dig it or they don't you don't
try and get them to dig you you know but
Andy Kaufman didn't care what you
thought of him yeah but I don't know
either no one no comedian that I respect
cares what you think they want you to
dig it Andy Kaufman I'm sure sometimes
designed it and he's one of my all-time
favorites designed it to where I'm gonna
do everything I can to get everyone to
leave the room or hate me but that was
just sort of more performance art type
things but in terms of when Andy Kaufman
was doing something that he thought was
funny like legitimately funny he didn't
care what you thought but he hoped you
dug it who makes you laugh harder
Seinfeld or Larry David Larry David in
terms of laughing harder yeah but Jerry
Seinfeld's one of my heroes one of the
greatest who's funnier off stage
off-camera are you doing Seinfeld and
Larry David again yeah
Jerry's gonna go what I'm not funny you
know you want the funniest people
offstage yeah there are yeah um let's
see here Amy Sedaris yes it makes me
laugh sorry I cry Conan O'Brien a Mitch
Hurwitz and uh you know created a
Arrested Development
crazy crazy funny yeah there's those are
some of the funniest and you and Conan
rooms we were roommates in Chicago yeah
how did that Wrigley Field not good for
him for me it was great because he made
me laugh so hard nice to wake him up at
like 3:00 in the morning and make him do
you know and also his room had no air
conditioning I remember that because
yeah he threw out his mattress when he
moved out the you got your sweatshirt
here just a kid kid from Chicago yeah
that's what I am just a kid from this is
actually um what's his name the names
it's a Derrick Rose thing that Gatorade
maybe made these or something and I
ordered one the first time I thought
they'd do it for other cities but the
dairy Derrick Rose was such a great
basketball player it's exciting to see
him have moments now you know yeah yeah
but he was just so amazing had 50 the
other night but when it comes to who
makes you cry of the Chicago team like
did the Bears make you cry or the Cubs
Cubs
well that was joy joy when they won the
world is here I I cried and I screamed
oh my god oh my god oh my god and
actually my son unbeknownst to me was
filming me when they won and I I love
the Cubs so much but uh not enough to go
to Cleveland so I went to the three
world cities such a die-hard fan I went
to the three World Series games in
Chicago but also I had to film the
Goldbergs so I had to come back but I I
watched it on TV and
I cried I wept no doubt about it an ice
cream Pauly's the Cubs apologist he went
streaking after they want that next
morning yeah it's no sense to me
whatsoever my little town in Fairfield
Connecticut I did nothing to do no one
it was awake and I just ran out my front
yard naked and said Cubs win Cubs win
and ran back inside that was it there
was no one there's a lot about you it
wasn't very gutsy there's no one I know
it's gutsy there's no any gutsy just you
being naked yeah that was good even in
your own home naked
that's gutsy I is in Wendy Wendy is
still on the Goldbergs right Wendy
mclendon-covey yes I made a movie Wendy
Willie McCovey yeah and now it's Wendy
Willie McCovey rest in peace I I made
out with her in a movie oh okay yeah did
you make out I was in a movie and a
Sandler movie blended and she plays my
wife oh really and it wasn't in the
script that I was going to make out with
her what happened she'd start making out
with you know Sandler goes you know
you're a handsome man thank you Jeff no
no you really are a handsome man I hope
you enjoy that I hope when you wake up
in the morning and you're look in the
mirror you go look at me but you're not
funny if you're handsome that's well
Ryan said no yes and no I think for
example Adam Sandler we mentioned I
think he's a very handsome handsome ish
no no you say yes he's very handsome
he's not like a stud like and by the way
here's the thing with comedy right now
that I find disturbing it's a trend and
that is there's too many good-looking
people doing comedy like there's guys
you said there's guys who I see on stage
doing stand-up who I know in high school
were bullies comedies not for bullies
comedies for the guys commenting on the
bullies trying to avoid the bullies
that's what comedies for good Brad Pitt
be if somebody wrote ten minutes could
Brad Pitt be funny is he too
good-looking why big he's funny he's
been funny in movies there was a Coen
Brothers movie of course I can't
remember where he was very funny I think
he has comedic chops but no he couldn't
do you know long it takes to be funny as
a stand-up
ten years minimum so would you've heard
Todd's been on stage three times you
just been it I got a long way to go
oh you Caroline's oh you did Caroline's
yeah Comedy Store yeah because of
because of Dan's connections he got me
into The Comedy Store a Monday night
which I had no business being up there
but to have done the carrot Caroline's
in Comedy Store for two of the three
times I've ever been onstage was you
know that's not lost on me what a big
deal that is with all the huge names
that have ever been on those days oh how
about that all right
that's not something you want to pursue
right now I love your boots key is
dabbling in becoming a comedian you you
go for it and that doesn't mean you
can't have this gig and go for it
but you really go for it or you don't
done should he quit this job
no really one no no no this is a great
gig well what advice would you cuz I
want him to script things he doesn't
write things down yeah he doesn't
tighten up his head a little outline
together but I feel like if I try to
memorize it it's not gonna come out here
here's the thing you have two choices
when you do when you perform comedy you
can do what I do which is I improvise
I'll even well I walk onstage plenty of
times having no idea what I'm gonna say
for the hour and it works out fine
because I've been doing it for 36 years
and I've figured out how to do that the
other thing is and this is the same with
comedic acting you have to know your
line so well and be over-prepared to the
point where you can make it look like
what's written is improvised so those
are your choices you either write
tightly and I would recommend early on
in your career writing tightly and being
prepared you know yeah so they've heard
all of this stuff fritzy no no but you
keep hearing it from people who do it
and then you don't you gotta get you got
to get out of your you know comfort zone
and try a different way here's the thing
I want to be clear about something okay
you have to go on stage 500 times
before you're even mediocre okay so
where are you at two three why are we
even having this conversation this is
somebody who's clearly not serious
clearly I'm dabbling I gotta get my act
together a little bit
who are you I don't get it I don't want
to deal with you anymore I used to have
great respect for you it's like he's
like a boxer it's like once every six
months he gets back into the ring and
then gets you don't do that so back to
what I was saying about making out with
Wendy yes no I'm just kidding oh you
didn't make out yeah was in the movie
but chance it's a big bowl of lovely
what a loan I was I was in a car with
her yesterday for 12 hours shooting
shooting just wanna make sure shooting a
being stuck in we were stuck in a car
with the Pina Colada song stoned and
Dave Koechner's in the scene and he
actually runs out of the car and
screamed in the middle of the highway
it's funny twelve hours okay here's your
question
if the Bears played the Rams yeah who do
you go bears okay
oh you mean who do I know who you don't
have no there's no loyalty I dig the
Rams I dig all the LA teams but I'm
Chicago you know bears everybody if you
want to go to the Lakers yeah do you
call or does Larry David call how's that
work by the way I would be very
uncomfortable calling up hey that's
actually a funny idea I'm gonna tell are
working on we start working on Saturday
for a while now I'm filming both the
Goldbergs and curb right now at the same
time which can be weird when it's the
same day
but yeah so yeah I started so I'll tell
that to Larry cuz that's really funny
actually
but and we did that episode where you
use my season tickets and he and he
tripped Shaquille O'Neal I love what the
rams are doing it's nice if you said
watch one episode of Curb oh it's I know
it I got it
wandering bear it's where Larry and I
are watching girls gone wild my dogs get
my dog gets run over but it's fine
Cheryl's vagina hurts and itches and
Larry's and wandering bear Larry's
gardener an Indian helps tries helping
her with her vagina
you know why it's all self gets all
contained in one episode and that's my
favorite episode
I still like when Larry kills the this
one oh this one yeah and it's just
unraveling you can just see a piece by
piece no that was uh that was a fun
episode to film the crazy thing about
that episode was there was a the scene
where we're having lunch and with Bob
Einstein Richard kind and and and Larry
when I'm well Larry's pretty normal and
I'm reasonably normal but Bob Einstein a
richer kind at the same table was just
and I was there for like ten hours with
these guys that's the thing like when
you see a dinner scene on a show I've
been sitting there he's Jeff Garlin
comedian actor producer director writer
the Goldbergs airs Wednesdays at 8:00 on
ABC and of course another season of Curb
Your Enthusiasm yeah very exciting thank
you for coming in hey it was an honor
and I'm thrilled and I love listening to
your show and you gentlemen are
fantastic except a stand-up comedians
just I'm a Dan I dig you man Thank You
Chuck thanks I appreciate them for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]